so california governor gavin newsom has  announced that the state of california  is going to start producing its own  insulin to make available to  californians at a low cost this is  unusual you don't typically see  american state governments get involved  in the manufacture of pharmaceuticals  but the situation with insulin is  absolutely insane now the right is going  to be going nuts about this  for one reason they will claim they will  say sir this is communism this is the  government taking over  a private business well not really it's  actually competing with private industry  it's competing with big pharma and the  real reason they're going to be scared  of it is it might work they might  actually  do better and make consumers more  satisfied with the lower priced insulin  than big pharma which big pharma doesn't  want it'll be a really interesting test  let me know what you think in the  comments good idea bad idea